the CNN star sharing with us all what
it's like to live the rock Ovid 19
crisis the virus works its way through
the family was me that was Christina now
Mario he's got the corona virus now at
night it's hard to get to the sinus
pressure but look this is how it works
in families I had a bit of a rough night
my son is now sick Chris's wife
Christina broke the news on Instagram
writing my heart hurts she disgusts
fourteen-year-old Mario's diagnosis
during a yoga livestream it's nice to
not feel that intense pain but it's even
worse to watch your child go through it
Christina says Mario's sense of smell
and taste have disappeared she had the
same symptoms a lot of prayers and set
some good intentions for my son please
because there is no mercy for children
chris has been on the mend assuring this
emotional end to his quarantine but with
both he and Christina getting sick was
it almost inevitable that Mario would
get the virus as well Christina told us
they took all the necessary precautions
I went through two boxes of gloves in
about ten days but she has a theory the
virus was passed along through the air
conditioning in the house the air
circulating is probably circulating
recirculating the jurors and I
definitely think that in the future
we're gonna learn more about just how
airborne this virus is family is super
important to the Cuomo's oldest daughter
bella has been helping around the house
and making tic TOCs with her dad
and as for Mario he is a beautiful soul
that kid Chris told us back in 2017
his son helped him become a kinder
person no I used to get angry a lot more
than I do now right Oh sweetie sensitive
he's all the things I wish I were
[Music]